joining the Rock at Sunday's Big Show
are fellow presenters recently blonde
Shania Twain Olivia Rodrigo Billy
Crystal and cardi B oh snappy snap snap
[Music]
but all eyes are on Beyonce
the pack with nine nominations and just
days after announcing her Renaissance
World Tour she's poised to make history
if she picks up four trophies she can
have the record for the most wins ever
let's be very clear that damn album is
insane B will battle Adele for the
biggest prize of the Night album of the
Year fans are holding out hope both
ladies will give surprise performances
just announced her hubby Jay-Z will take
the stage with DJ Khaled and John Legend
another thing we know for sure
I feel incredibly lucky to make music as
my job every day Harry
still hit the stage when the Grammys air
live Coast to Coast
in a minute he joins pal lizzo the two
are even sitting next to each other
we'll also see performances by Luke
Combs Bad Bunny Sam Smith Kim Petras and
the queen of Hip-Hop soul Mary J Blige
just be prepared to have a good time the
show is crazy y'all can stop me now and
speaking of hip-hop LL Cool J Will
introduce a celebration of the genre
including Missy Elliott Run DMC and salt
and Peppa with Spinderella
it's going to be beautiful she'll be
celebrating 50 years of a music genre
that from the very beginning was
discarded you can't deny that hip-hop
truly is in its moment Trevor Noah hosts
for the third year in a row and watch
out for big first timers including Viola
Davis going for an egot and Machine Gun
Kelly
this is the envelope with where they
read my name on it so I'm like
it is a surreal title to have and I
thought about it and I thought to myself
if I achieved that
I may take myself out to dinner
[Music]